So the last time we talked, I talked to you
about how the knowledge structures that we
inhabit might be built from the bottom up.
So I’m showing you this diagram because
it might clarify that a little bit.
What you see at the top - this is a hierarchy,
a partially built hierarchy and so one way
of thinking of an attribute like good when
you apply it to a person, or bad or evil or
wonderful, one way to think about it is as
a description of an object, but it’s not
really.
It’s shorthand for a set of - well I think
of them as micro personalities, but you can
also think about them as behavioral patterns.
Now, one of the things I mentioned to you
about - I talked to you a little bit about
words at one point, and what words signify
and this is a very complicated problem so
most of you are probably Augustinians without
even knowing it because St. Augustine originally
proposed that a word was a label for a thing.
Of course, that’s how people naturally think.
I’m sure most of you would regard that definition
as perfectly suitable, but it’s by no means
the only definition and it’s by no means
necessarily the correct definition.
There's a famous philosopher named Wittgenstein
who proposed instead that a word was like
a piece in a chess game which meant that it
was something that you did something with,
or you might think about it actually as a
tool.
And when you think about how you use words,
you can see that you're using them often as
tools to interact with other people for a
purpose.
What I like about the tool idea - the tool
idea is a very evolutionary sophisticated
concept, partly because we’re tool using
creatures probably beyond our other capacities
except for possibly imitation and language
which set us so far apart from other animals,
but the thing about a tool is that the difference
between a tool and an object doesn't have
a user.
The word object doesn't imply user, but the
word tool implies user, and it’s not obvious
that we ever interact with anything in the
world without interacting with it in some
motivated way.
And so, what we’re doing is we’re using
words to get through the world.
To interact properly within the world and
to move where we want to go.
So that’s the second way of thinking about
a word.
Here’s another way of thinking about a word.
A word is like a box of things and so imagine
that you cleaned out your basement and there's
a bunch of boxes downstairs and one box is
labeled books.
Well inside that box, there could be any manner
of books.
Books is a very very diverse set of phenomena.
If you're moving, books are kind of condensed
into one thing which are kind of heavy objects
made out of paper.
You can also imagine another box that says
things.
And in the thing box, I’m sure you have
a thing drawer at home where you put all the
things you don't know what to do with so it’s
like the category of all things you don't
know what to do with.
Things.
Okay so a word can also represent a relatively
heterogenous set of tools or entities.
That’s very very very useful to know because
one of the things that happens often when
people are arguing is that they use the same
word but each word contains a set of different
objects.
You might say for example, is fear real?
Questions like that are very strange.
They're not really answerable in some sense
because it depends on exactly what you mean
by fear because fear can contain a lot of
heterogenous entities, roughly speaking, and
it means - it also depends on what you mean
by real.
So you can define fear and you can define
real and so that fear is a subcategory of
real or you can define fear and you can define
fear so that fear isn’t a subset of real.
So, the idea that fear is a box that only
contains a certain set of entities or a certain
set of tools and that reality is the same
is wrong, and people argue about those sorts
of things all the time, and they make these
binary questions.
Is X a Y?
Well, X and Y are generally not well enough
to find so that you can easily find an answer
to a binary question like that.
Okay so, words can also represent a relatively
heterogenous set of attributes or objects
or tools.
When you say that someone’s a good person
for example, you don’t mean they’re a
good person all the time or that everything
they’ve ever done is good because they wouldn't
be a good person then, they would be a saint
or some other fictional character like that.
So, when you’re applying the label - we’ll
call it label for the purposes of this argument.
It’s a descriptive tool actually.
When you’re applying a term like that to
someone, it’s a shorthand for a variety
of states that this person could exist in.
The majority of which you regard as positive.
You might say he’s a better person than
she is, and then you’d say well the proportion
of attributes that she has - I think I said
she, whatever - it exceeds the proportion
of positives that this other person has.
So the other way you can think about a word
is - this is more complicated, it involves
a little bit of visualization.
So imagine you have a child’s train on a
track.
It’s going around and around the track.
And it’s got cars on it that you can put
things in, and all the cars are full of things,
and then on the track there’s a box with
cutouts in it so that the train can pass through,
and on top of the box is a word.
And the word is things, and the train is going
through the box.
In some sense, what that would mean - imagine
the train is long enough - at any given second,
the box of things would contain different
things, but it would still be a box of things.
And a lot of words we use are like that.
Not only do they represent a heterogenous
set of entities, but the set changes depending
on the context that we use the word in.
So the reason I’m telling you that is because
a word, here’s another way of thinking about
a word.
This will be good for you computer - well
you’re all computer people now of course.
A word is a low resolution image.
So you think about it.
A word is a good enough approximation of the
thing that it’s representing.
Sort of like a thumbnail.
Now obviously one of the differences of a
thumbnail and the real thing is that the real
thing exists at a much more, much higher level
of resolution.
It exists at many, many more layers.
You can use the thumbnail to represent it.
The advantage to doing that is that it doesn’t
take up much processing time, and it doesn’t
take up much memory.
So lots of time, you want to use the shorthand
for the thing rather than the thing because
it’s just too complicated otherwise.
And then you might say well how do you know
your shorthand representation is a good representation
of the thing you're trying to represent, and
the pragmatists would say well it depends
on what you want to do with it.
That’s the tool-like aspect.
It’s like if you’re using word X to represent
potentially heterogeneous class Y, and when
you use it, you get to where you're want or
you get close enough to where you want, then
it’s good enough.
So it’s like how you know a joke is good
enough, well someone laughs.
Okay, the joke is good enough, and so one
of the things that’s quite interesting about
the way you interact with the world, and this
is something the pragmatists really discovered
in some sense, was that you're always aiming
at some bounded set of events that’s somewhat
different than the current set of events because
otherwise you could just sit there, and then
you put your conceptions to work and your
actions to work to manage the transformation,
and if you manage the transformation, then
it’s good enough.
You don’t have to go any farther than that.
So that explains partly how you can maneuver
in the world with limited knowledge.
You use low resolution representations to
partially hit vague goals, and that generally
gets you there.
That process was called satisficing by - now
what’s his name, an extraordinarily famous
economist and psychologist.
Anyone remember who coined the word satisficing?
Well, an economist psychologist would be Herb
Simon.
That’s right, it’s Simon.
It was Herb Simon, and you know he said well,
you’re often not out to optimize.
Let’s say in a search for a partner, to
optimize it you’d have to search through
several billion people.
Well you’re not gonna do that because you
don’t have the time.
So then you might say well, you don’t know
exactly how to do it but it’s something
this.
You have five attributes that you’re looking
for and maybe two that you don’t know you’re
looking for but you are looking for, and the
first person that comes along that matches
those well enough, you pick.
So it’s not an optimization issue, but given
that you have a limited amount of time, you
can’t wait around for optimized solutions.
You have to go ahead with sufficient, and
then move to the next issue.
Okay, so all that’s a conceptual precursor
for taking a look at this diagram.
So we’re calling someone a good person.
So what does it mean?
Well we’re going to do a bit of a microanalysis.
We’re going to assume it’s a bit of a
shorthand, low resolution representation of
the person and that you can decompose it.
If someone says X is a - Henry is a good person,
and maybe he’s 45.
You might say does he have children?
Then you might say yes.
Then you might say well is he a good parent
because you might assume that if he’s a
good person, he might be a good parent.
Now it’s conceivable that he can be a good
parent without being a good parent if he was
good at five other important things.
But let’s assume as a good person he’s
also a good parent.
I think it’s reasonable to assume that good
parent would be a subset of good person, right,
because it’s more specific.
More specific means it covers less time and
space in some sense because good person is
a description of a person that covers how
the person interacts with the world across
the broadest possible amount of time and location.
And then good parent, well you can find that
out when they’re interacting with children
let’s say for the sake of argument.
There’s other issues, and then you might
say well if he’s a good parent what does
he have to do to be a good parent?
Well he has to feed his children so he probably
needs a job, and it would be better if it
was a good job.
So he’s got a good job and that’s part
of being a good person.
And then maybe he can care for his family
and so care might be regarded as a more specific
subset of good parent, and so you can decompose
caring to, let’s say, play with baby, and
then you can decompose play into - well I
decomposed it into peek, tickle, and clean.
What’s interesting about this is those are
all abstractions, but once you get down to
a high enough level of resolution, they’re
no longer abstractions in that they’re actually
actions you undertake in the world.
Moving your hand is not an abstraction.
So at some point - and this is a nice elegant
solution to the mind body problem to some
degree.
At some level of resolution - high resolution
- it stops being conceptual and starts being
action, and that's where the mind hits the
world.
If you go into an even higher level of resolution
than that, like what do you have to do to
move your hand?
The answer to that is you don’t know.
You just do it.
And so your consciousness bottoms out, in
some sense, at the level of motor activity.
So there’s a level above which you can’t
perceive which are the networks that you're
involved in and there’s a level below which
you can’t perceive, which is under normal
circumstances, procedural control which is
whatever enables you to actually move.
So then you might say well what are all of
these things.
How would you conceptualize a decomposed good
person.
Well then you might say well what are all
these things made out of?
In a sense, what are their constituent elements?
Good person, good parent, family care, play
with baby.
They're sort of like games.
They're sort of like stories.
They're sort of like rituals.
I think about them in these terms, so if you
look at - that’s where we get to this particular
diagram which we’re gonna concentrate on
quite a bit.
Let me shift to it and we’ll talk about
that.
Now I don’t exactly know how to - what to
call this thing.
I think the best way of thinking about it
is it’s a subpersonality and that the reason
I call it a subpersonality is because only
a personality has all the attributes that
this thing has and so the attributes are.
I talked to you last week about the fact that
the Russian neuropsychologist for example
felt that people had to build models of the
world and so you can call this a model of
the world.
So the reason they suspected that was because
if you brought someone - I think I ran through
this - if you bring someone into a laboratory
and you play them a tone, when they first
hear the tone they manifest an orienting reflex
which is a change in skin conduction, and
that’s actually a consequence of neurological
activity.
And then if you play the tone a bunch, they
stop having the reaction and then if you vary
the tone on any perceptible dimension, the
orienting reflex returns, and so the inference
from that is obviously the person must be
constructing a model of the tone because otherwise
how would they know if something deviated
from it, especially on all those dimensions.
So not only is it a model, it’s a multi-dimensional
model.
Okay, now the upshot of that is for a long
time, people tried to figure out how in the
world we model the world, and then they tried
to figure out how to make smart machines that
modeled the world that could then plan their
actions in the modeled world and then could
act in the world as a consequence.
They got nowhere with that because it turned
out that the world is so damn complex that
if you’re gonna model it, you’re gonna
spend all the time modeling.
You’re not gonna spend your time acting
in it and you’re not gonna get anywhere.
It’s partly because the world is almost
infinitely complex, and so if you're trying
to get a computer to look at the world, you
might say well what is the computer supposed
to look at?
Everything.
Well, no.
I mean, you look at a lot in some ways, and
not very much in others, and half your brain
is dedicated, roughly speaking, to visual
processing.
Then you’ve got your other senses to help
you figure out what’s going on.
But you don’t build a model of the whole
world.
You don’t build any model at all of the
parts of the world that aren’t relevant
to you.
For example, your model of this floor is very
low resolution.
If I took you guys out in the hallway, assuming
the hallway floor isn't the same color and
I said, what was the color of this floor.
You would not be able to tell me, and the
reason for that is who cares.
It could be shifting color all the time while
you’re sitting here, you know, subtly, and
you’re not gonna care.
The reason for that is you’re not falling
through it, and it isn’t moving.
So it’s like an invisible presupposition
of your current knowledge structure.
And there's all sorts of things going on around
you that are like that.
You don't pay attention to the walls.
You really don't pay attention to the people
that are around you.
They could sort themselves in a different
way.
You wouldn't notice unless you know the person.
There's also all sorts of things that you
don't model.
Now you’ve all seen the invisible gorilla
video, I presume.
Everyone’s seen that.
Is there anyone here who hasn't seen that
video.
Okay good.
So that’s something eh.
It’s really something that there's a psychology
experiment that's so well known you can talk
to a crowd now and almost everyone’s seen
it.
It’s so shocking.
It’s like, of course I can see a gorilla
if one was dancing around on a basketball
court.
It’s like, ha no you wouldn’t.
Or there's a fifty percent chance you wouldn’t.
Now the reason for that is, fundamentally
speaking, is you're given a task when you
watch that video, and the task is to count
the number of times the ball is thrown by
the team in black.
All of a sudden, your perceptual systems reorient
themselves and you're not really looking at
people.
You’re looking at something that might be
animated stick figures who are engaged, momentarily,
in moving the object of perceptual importance
around.
So you can blur them out, which you do because
obviously you can’t tell the difference
between a gorilla and the person dressed in
black.
The reason you can’t is you don't need to.
In order to fulfill the task, you can treat
all the people like vaguely moving black objects,
and as long as that doesn't interfere with
your counting, then it’s irrelevant.
So actually, you don’t build a model of
the whole world.
And you build a model of only the parts of
the world that are relevant to your ongoing
micro action.
Now the problem that brings up is how do you
know what’s relevant.
Well that’s a tough question.
I would say, the reason you know what’s
relevant is because some things don’t change
over time, and you’ve been evolving through
three and a half billion years.
So you’ve built yourself.
If we go back to that other diagram, you can
imagine the levels there from the micro activities
to the abstractions.
You think about how much building had to go
in so you could undertake those microactions.
So like, here you can move your hand.
Well that’s great.
How do you get the hand?
Well, you know, it took a long time.
It took almost all of the three and a half
billion years before you managed to come up
with a hand.
So, even underneath the microactions, there's
this massive evolutionary history that's been
built up partially as a consequence of some
of the unchanging features of the environment,
or at least in consequence to some of the
slower changing features of the environment
that has given you this incredibly complex
body that’s really good at doing some things
and not really good at doing other things
at all.
And so, that’s how you solve the relevance
problem, and I actually think it’s one of
the most powerful arguments for the necessity
of evolutionary theory.
It’s like this problem is so complex because
it’s not only how you have to adapt to the
environment across time.
So you have to build a body that adapts to
the environment.
It’s worse than that.
It’s like the train passing through the
box.
The environment is not stable.
It keeps shifting and turning and moving and
twisting, and so not only do you have to adapt
to the environment, you have to adapt flexibly
to the environment while it transforms itself
at different levels of totality because sometimes
there’s minor changes to the environment.
Sometimes a meteor hits the Earth and we’re
plunged into darkness for four years, or there’s
an ice age or something like that.
So the levels of transformation in the environment
can be radical and the evolutionary process
has to keep up with that.
The way it works, apparently, like I don’t
believe this is the whole story although it’s
more or less the whole Darwinian story is
that something more or less works and it makes
a million copies of itself and there's tiny
variations in those copies often at least
in principle because of copying error which
is where I think the theory is weak.
And then they all die except for two.
And so, why didn't those die, and the answer
is well they happened by chance to vary in
the direction that the environment varied
and so they get to continue and so the reason
evolution works is that everything dies.
Everything fails because you think well, keeping
up with a randomly changing environment is
impossible, so how do you do it?
Well you do a million things.
Most of them don't work, but you only have
to succeed enough to propagate yourself once.
Now, so I think that that’s not exactly
right because I don't believe that our understanding
of evolution is complete.
There’s a bunch of things that I don't believe
in.
One is DNA is pretty damn complex.
It’s not obvious how it could have evolved,
and even the people who discovered DNA were
very very complexed that it existed.
So one of them - and I told you this - thought
that it came from outer space and that it
had evolved from somewhere else.
You might think about that as crazy theory
but cosmic winds, like solar winds and that
kind of thing, can propel tiny things vast
distances relatively rapidly, and over 13.5
billion years you can really get around.
I think the estimates, even if you used sub
- if you used transportation methods that
are about the speed that we have, you can
colonize the whole galaxy in some like 20
million years because it’s exponential.
20 million years is a tiny tiny subset of
3.5 billion years so it’s not as far fetched
as it sounds.
The problem is it doesn't address the problem.
Okay it came from somewhere else, but how
did it get there?
It just pushes the problem back.
But there's this other issue too which is
called epigenesis, and that's really put an
old spoke in the scientific wheels in the
last twenty years because the theory was,
twenty years ago, that all evolution preceded
through random mutation, and it was random.
But it turns out that's not exactly right
because there had been a number of demonstrations
that if something happens to generation A,
that will produce a transformation in the
genetic information that's transferred to
generation B. And the transformation often
seems not merely as a consequence of damage,
but actually a form of adaptation to the new
environment.
Now that’s a tough one, like twenty years
ago when I was studying evolutionary psychology
and evolutionary biology, if someone would
have said, well you can transmit acquired
characteristics, it would have been like you’re
over there with the creationists because that
was no go.
That was against the rules.
But it does happen, and the fact that epigenesis
happens at all means that there's a lot of
things about how DNA works that we don't know.
I actually think what's happening is that
DNA is a very very complex microcomputer,
and I don’t know exactly how it operates,
maybe it’s a quantum computer.
It’s very complex.
Remember it’s had three and a half billion
years to figure out what's going on, and it’s
pretty good at surviving.
So you don’t want to underestimate it, and
the structures it builds at the molecular
level are so complex it just - if you - there’s
some great animations of those things going
on at the molecular level on the net.
They're so complex that you can't help but
think of them as computational when you watch
them.
They're not random processes man.
Like I watched the little molecule that checks
for error in a DNA replication string.
I mean, it checks for errors in a DNA replication
string man.
To figure out how it does something like that
without some form of computation strikes me
as impossible.
Anyways I think what happens is that over
time the DNA plays, like it can manifest itself
in many different forms and it also capitalizes
on mutation.
I think that's how it works.
Now you know there's other I’d say kind
of weak evidence for that.
Maybe it’s only evidence by analogy but
if I take one of you and I put you in a radically
new environment, new genes will turn on in
your brain and code for new proteins and so
it’s like you're sitting there but in some
sense there’s a whole set of potential yous
that are sitting there.
A lot of that potential is actually locked
in the genetic code.
I mean, it’s dependant on the information
that's in the environment around it cause
it’s not all in the code but it’s enough
to get the process started.
So if I take you out of situation A and put
you in situation B, you build new brain structures
at the microlevel.
So you’re actually a different person.
That's actually a very interesting way of
thinking about the consequences of something
like exposure in psychotherapy.
It’s like okay, you're all timid and there's
eighteen things you're terrified of.
You go out and master one of them.
It’s like poof, your brain is the not the
same.
Maybe you're a little braver.
And then you go master another one, and a
bunch more of you turns on.
Now I don't know if one thing turns on, something
else turns off.
You know what I mean is that there's only
so much of you that can be turned on at any
one time, but maybe a lot of more you can
be turned on than is turned on, so.
I think it looks like that because people
who really challenge themselves across the
span of their life, they develop talents in
multiple directions.
People can really be amazingly good at a ridiculous
number of things.
Okay so, Sokolov and Vinogradova showed that
you model the world right down to the finest
details, but then Dan Simon and his crew showed
“No you don’t, you’re so blind you can't
even believe it.”
It’s like okay, those are not the same set
of facts, so how do we reconcile that?
Well here’s one way of getting a bit of
sense of it.
Look straight ahead.
Okay, now concentrate not on what you see
in the middle of your vision but at the sides.
It’s probably better if you look at a person
to do that, but it doesn’t really matter
though.
So look straight ahead but pay attention to
what you see in the periphery.
So I can tell you what you’ll see because
some of it is very difficult to detect.
Way out in the periphery, it’s black and
white.
You can't tell that though.
But we know that because if we change colors
way out in the periphery on you, you can't
detect a change.
And then out to about here, if something isn't
moving, it’s almost impossible to see it.
But as soon as it moves, you can see that
there’s something moving.
Sort of like dinosaur vision.
Remember Jurassic Park?
Don’t move because the dinosaur can see
you.
It’s like well, you have dinosaur movement
detector still built into your nervous system.
And the answer is why, and the answer is well
if you can't afford to have a lot of your
brain wired up in the periphery of your vision
because your head is only so big, then you
have to concentrate on only those things that
are most likely to be relevant.
And moving things are more likely to be relevant
because they can eat you.
Moving things are more likely to be relevant
than stationary things especially if you've
been in the environment for a while right,
because if you're in here it’s like the
stationary things are going to stay stationary
so you can ignore them.
You don't even have to see them, but the moving
things, they’re transforming at a time rate
that’s relevant to you so it’s good to
be able to detect those.
Now the periphery of your vision is actually
wired in more directly to your - to the lower
levels of your nervous system.
So it can trigger off things like startle
reflexes which are very rapid, and it can
also trigger an orienting response which is
the movement of your sensory systems in the
direction of the stimulus so if something
over here moves, then you go like that, and
then what you're doing is you're nailing it
with your central vision.
Now, out in your peripheral vision, if you
follow the optical tract back to your brain,
you'll see the peripheral retinal nerves don't
attach to a tremendous number of visual cortex
neurons, but the central ones do so each of
the central neurons in your central vision
- the fovea.
Each one of those is connected to ten thousand
neurons at the first level of elaboration,
and then each neuron is connected to about
ten thousand other neurons.
So it’s ten thousand to the ten thousandth
two neurons in and so a lot of your brain
is focusing on that tiny little pinpoint that
you use that’s foveal vision, and it seems
to be about big enough so that you can bring
a face into high resolution in the center
and you can track the movement of the various
elements of the faces.
If you look at someone and you look about
eighteen inches to their left or to their
right, you'll see that you can't see their
nose anymore.
You see kind of a vague outline of their face.
You can still see the color.
You can detect their eyebrows, and you can
detect their mouth especially if their mouth
moves or their eyes move.
You just zero in on that right away.
What’s happening is that way out here, your
vision is incredibly low resolution and the
resolution increases to the center where it’s
very very high, and then there's some tweaks
like okay you can't really see out here, but
you can see motion, and that's good enough
because as soon as something moves, you can
turn your head cause you can turn your head
and your eyes and you can focus that little
pinpoint on it and dance around cause that's
what you do with the pinpoint.
It moves around very rapidly, and you can
scan that central area with high resolution.
So it’s an efficient use of limited resources.
So partly the way that you manage in the world
which is very very complicated, is that even
your senses simplify it for you.
There's only - you can't see the entire spectrum
of electromagnetic radiation.
You can only see the visual light spectrum.
It’s very narrow.
There’s a whole range of sounds you can't
hear.
There's things you can't smell.
So you're in a box and some things get through,
but not everything.
So that simplifies things for you right off
the bat and hypothetically those things you
do detect or those things where it was necessary
for you to detect for you to be here, over
this vast span of time and no doubt there
were variants all the way through that tried
to parse it up differently - slightly differently
- and that didn't work out as well so they
aren't around.
So you’re around because of death and replication.
So it’s an interesting take on death, eh,
because you're the product of an unbelievable
number of deaths.
Right, because all of those experiments had
to take place in some sense for you to be
here at all.
So anyways, okay, then, so you can see with
your central vision that you focus in on one
point and you reduce the others to low resolution
representations, maybe even cartoons, and
then I also think, although I don't know this
for sure and someone has undoubtedly done
the work.
My suspicions are that in the periphery, you
don't update - you know how your screen updates.
It’s sixty cycles a second, something like
that.
You update your vision at about sixty cycles
per second, and we know that because if the
screen resolution or if the screen update
decreases below sixty cycles a second, people
can start to see it flicker.
So we have a refresh rate.
It’s around sixty hertz.
Some people can see flicker at higher hertz
than that, but most people can't.
Sixty is about right.
So, that's another way that you deal with
the fact that there's way too much for you
to deal with.
Your temporal resolution isn't very high,
you know, so the smallest meaningful event
for you is about a tenth of a second long.
Now if you're in a car accident or you're
in some situation where it’s an emergency
and you get a massive burst of dopamine, you
might be able to speed that processing up
by a hundredfold.
Who knows?
But you're gonna be absolutely exhausted instantly
when you do that.
I don't know if you've ever experienced that
in a car accident or something like that but
people often report that time slows down dramatically,
but then afterwards they're just done.
So the reason you don't see a thousand times
as fast as you do is because you’d have
to be eating like a hummingbird right.
You'd need a big vat of nectar attached to
you, and you'd just be sipping on it or gulping
it down nonstop.
So you're also restricted in terms of your
temporal resolution.
Okay, well then what else do you do to simplify
the world.
Well this is where the tool concept of concept,
the tool concept of concept starts to become
useful because you're actually aiming at things
all the time, and I really like the aim metaphor
because if you understand the metaphor well,
it really sheds some light on what human beings
are like.
Chimps are hunters, but they're not hunters
like human beings are hunters.
We’re really really good hunters.
Chimps, they have to kind of mob an animal
and then they’ll tear it apart, and they
like meat so they’ll definitely do it.
But human beings have been hunting in an unbelievably
sophisticated way for a tremendous amount
of time, and there's a bunch of things about
us that aren't like chimps.
So one is we can throw, and our bodies are
built for throwing.
Now you might think well that's not that relevant
but if something is chasing you through the
bush and you can throw a rock at it, it becomes
relevant very quickly.
And so we’re really good at taking projectiles,
specifying targets, and hurling the projectiles
at targets.
And we can do that with rocks, and we can
do it with bows, and we can do it with rifles,
and we can do it with rifles, and we can do
it with nuclear weapons.
And so there's something about us that's obsessed
with hitting the middle of the target.
Now there's an interesting side note for that
which is that the word sin is derived from
the Greek word “Hamartia,” and hamartia
is an archery term to mean to miss the center
of the target.
Now that's something very much worth thinking
about.
It’s a very lovely concordance.
So we’re built on this hunting platform.
We can track moving things extraordinarily
well.
We have amazing eyesight.
Our eyesight’s better than any primate by
a huge amount, and better than any other creature
except for hawks and other birds of prey.
So, and, we also use - so we have this intense,
amazing capacity to zero in and here’s some
cool things about your eyes.
So, if you look at a gorilla, you’ll see
that a gorilla doesn't really have whites
in their eyes, and you might think well that's
kind of weird because we do, and so what's
the hypothesis?
Well, if I’m looking at somebody at the
back of the room, I can tell if they're looking
at my eyes.
If they're looking at my nose, it’s almost
as if their face just gets a little bit vaguer
like we’re not communicating.
It’s eye to eye contact.
So our ability to specify the direction in
which another person’s eyes are pointing
is phenomenal.
And you might say, well why?
Well first of all, there’s a lot of expression
around the eyes right.
So you can imagine coevolution.
The coevolution is sharper and sharper vision.
Vision associated with detecting eyes and
then also more and more evolution for emotional
expression around the eyes.
So there's that.
But then, the other thing that I wanted - the
reason that I would be interested in that
is because I want to know what the hell you’re
up to because maybe you're a friend and maybe
you're a foe or maybe you're interested in
something that I should be interested in.
So we know what people are like in that regard,
so you go stand out in the corner and you
look up, and soon there are ten people you
have around you looking up.
And why is that?
It’s because when they see where your eyes
are pointed and embody you, they think well
that person - they don’t think this.
It’s the equivalent of thinking.
They think well that person must be looking
at something interesting because that's what
people look at, and if it’s interesting
to them then it’s probably going to be interesting
to me especially if it’s in the sky.
It’s like what the hell, that’s not supposed
to be happening.
So you're looking at people’s eyes because
you want to know what they're up to in their
facial display, which is your face is unbelievably
innervated and controllable, both by conscious
and by unconscious means.
That tells you what they're up to, which is
why you want to see someone’s face.
You don't talk to the back of their head.
You want to talk to their face, and you don't
like it when they're looking like this or
looking like that or failing to make eye contact.
Although too much eye contact is a predatory
stare.
So you know, you’ve got -
Well you’ve got to get the balance right.
So now, what about the whites of the eyes?
Well the theory is that the reason we’ve
developed whites is because it was easier
to see where someone’s eyes were pointed
if there was a dark circle in a white space,
and what that basically meant was that all
your ancestors who were a little less fortunate
on the eye white side either didn't mate or
got killed.
Probably in misunderstandings.
So, our eyes stand out against this bright
white background because that helps us - that
helps other people detect what we’re up
to, and that means we can trust each other
more easily and we can - even as something
as simple as like eye contact in a situation
where there’s a possibility of finding a
sexual partner is a very important component
of that because eye contact indicates interest
and it also indicates, at least in principle,
the possibility of approach.
And so approach is dopaminergically mediated
and it’s a positive emotional state.
And that’s also why, interestingly enough,
if you go into a pharmacy, and there's a rack
of magazines, and they're - what's on the
cover?
Always.
Almost always.
Beautiful women.
Like on fifty percent of the men’s magazines
there's a beautiful woman and on like a hundred
percent of the women’s magazines which is
really interesting you know because you might
think well why is that?
Women’s eyes are always looking out in a
way that they're looking at you.
So there was some interest - so it’s an
invocation of interest, and so, you know,
magazines evolve.
All the ones that don’t get bought fail.
And so what’s happened is they've all converged
to the same point, and the same point is that
the thing that's maximally interesting to
a magazine purchaser is a beautiful female
face.
Whether it’s male or female.
Now on the male side, there's also gadgets
of all sorts.
And that may be that men are more gadgets
oriented than women.
So anyways, and we also know that for example
with men, if you show them - this is a funny
little study.
So you show them a face of a beautiful woman
and her eyes are looking that way, or this
way or they're looking right at him, you can
check the activity in the dopaminergic center
in a place called the nucleus accumbens which
is the same that cocaine hits.
Face on eye contact, that thing lights up.
It lights up even more if she’s wearing
a red dress.
Right, and you can get the same kind of lighting
up with a red curvy sports car.
Yeah.
So it’s the, you know - my thought when
I read that was the perfect situation is like
a beautiful girl dressed in red perched on
a sports car, with some cocaine.
Why red?
That’s a good question.
I’m not exactly sure why - oh that's wrong.
I do know why red.
Ripe fruit.
Women have coevolved with ripe fruit.
It’s very sneaky of you by the way.
So that's why - you know that too.
You just have to leaf through a women’s
magazine.
Lipstick is always associated with like apples
that are glistening in some way, or a peach
or something like that.
And we were primarily fruit eaters, and the
reason we have color vision is to detect fruit,
ripe fruit.
So part of the reason that - also part of
the reason that fruit turns red or colors
when it ripens is because the fruit that was
successfully eaten by creatures that distributed
the seeds was the fruit that was ripe when
it was eaten.
So as the color vision evolved, maybe there
was a red tint for only god knows what reason,
then a positive feedback loop developed and
fruit got redder and redder, and at the same
time, women capitalized on that.
So that’s partly, I think, what explains
the association between Eve and the apple
in Genesis because Genesis is also a story
about gaining sight.
So yeah, that’s why red.
That’s pretty funny.
I really think that's pretty funny.
You know, evolved sensory significance is
absolutely everywhere.
It’s so deep inside of us.
Yeah.
I have to wonder about blood too, that seems
like it also
Oh yeah, yeah.
Red’s a significant color, but I think - I
mean and it’s funny too because say there’s
a flushed face, well that means it’s infused
with blood.
It’s also a sign of health.
It’s also a sign of sexual arousal.
But it is a sign of health, and so you see
in old Coke ads from the 1930’s, the girl’s
cheeks are so red it looks like she has a
fever.
So it’s a form of sexual signalling that
indicates health.
So that's another part.
I mean these are multiply determined right,
as anything as complex as vision.
Yeah, and blood means “Hey, maybe don’t
go there” or maybe it means there’s something
to eat.
Right, right.
Yup.
There was another theory with color sight,
and it had to do with people’s facial expressions
- not expressions but depending on whether
you're angry or aroused.
Oh definitely, you can see that those things
would loop together.
Once the color vision starts to adapt, the
color vision for fruit is way older, I would
suspect, because when we developed it, we
had fur.
But once the ability’s there and we lose
our facial fur, it’s possible to capitalize
on the ability to detect the signalling.
And you know, we’re talking about a transformation
that's over about - we were living in trees
about sixty million years ago.
So the transition between us and them is sixty
million years.
The separation between chimps is about seven.
And you know, chimp skin is so dark, you’re
not gonna get a lot of signalling.
Okay so, back to this little diagram.
Now here’s the idea.
This is deeply informed, although I didn't
know it when I was working on these ideas,
this is deeply informed by a guy named Norbert
Wiener who was one of the twentieth century’s
massive geniuses and a force behind the development
of computation.
So this is a cybernetic model.
He invented cybernetics.
Now I didn't learn this from Norbert Wiener
because I learned it from Jeffrey Gray, but
Jeffrey Gray’s source had learned it from
Norbert Wiener way back in the 1940’s.
In fact there was a convention back in the
1940’s that Wiener presented many of his
ideas at that many psychologists attended,
including Jean Piaget.
So Piaget’s theory is very much influenced
by cybernetics as well.
Many many of the standard psychology cognitive
models are cybernetic.
So they're grounded in thinking that's grounded
in the engineering thinking and not psychological
thinking at all.
Yup.
Isn’t Humberd’s book called Cybernetics?]
No, Dianetics.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay so, how might you conceptualize the fundamental
elements of a personality.
Well, this is what it looks like to me.
The first thing is you're a moving creature.
So here's a funny story.
There's a little animal whose name I forget,
and in its - it’s an ocean animal - in its
juvenile state, it swims around.
Okay so in its juvenile state, it has to coordinate
its movements and interact with the changing
environment.
So it has a brain.
But when it turns into an adult, it attaches
itself to a rock and turns into something
like a piece of coral.
It promptly digests its own brain.
So the issue is unless you don't really need
a brain if you're not gonna go anywhere right.
So a brain is a going places thing, and we
have a very big brain and so it’s like we’re
always zooming around doing things, and we've
got these hands that enable us to manipulate
things and transform things.
So the brain is for doing things, it’s not
just for perceiving.
Roughly speaking, the back half of your brain
is for perception, the cortical part.
Mostly visual perception, but some auditory
and touch.
A lot of visual, and the front part is for
output.
Motor action.
And as you proceed - imagine the front part
starts halfway here.
As you proceed from the midline forward, the
action becomes more and more abstract until
when you're dealing with the dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex, you're thinking abstractly.
Now people think that when they're thinking
abstractly, they're thinking about representations
of the world because we think about objects,
but that isn't what we’re doing.
What we’re doing is rehearsing potential
schemas of action.
So we have this abstract space, which you
might think about as a duplicate world.
You have an idea.
You test the idea like you would test it if
you were acting in the world, and the consequence
of the imaginary testing is if you encounter
grief, then you don't implement the idea in
the world.
Now you know, that doesn't always work because
there's trade offs between short term pleasure
and long term punishment that makes it complicated,
but what seems to have happened is that as
we've evolved, we’re very sneaky creatures
you know.
For billions of years, the only way that you
could figure out whether you're right or wrong
was to go out and do something, and if you
died you were wrong.
But now, you can think about doing something
and if the consequence of running the simulation
in your head is that you die, then you don't
do it.
So what you're basically doing is spinning
off multiple potential use in multiple potential
universes and running them as simulations.
Now we really do that now because we’ve
externalized it onto the computer which is
what we’re doing with really really complex
video games.
So it’s so smart.
It’s an amazing evolutionary advance.
Now it doesn't work that well because sometimes
you run the simulation and you think, this
is a stupid idea, and you promptly have eight
beers so that you can go do it.
But, all things considered, that’s still
what this abstract space is for.
I should tell you something about this too
because you're gonna hear from neuropsychologists
that a lot of what the dorsolateral prefrontal
cortex does is - the cortex in general - is
impulse control, and that’s wrong.
That is not what it does.
And part of the reason I know this is because
the correlation between prefrontal cortical
cognitive ability which is very tightly associated
with IQ by the way.
The correlation is like 0.9 so you can even
argue it’s the same thing.
Fluid IQ in particular.
The correlation between dorsolateral prefrontal
cognitive capacity and conscientiousness which
is like long term goal directed, future oriented,
planned activity is zero.
Okay zero is a very bad correlation.
You know the old idea, correlation doesn’t
imply causality.
Well, wrong.
It does strongly imply causality.
It doesn't demonstrate it because with every
causal relationship, there's a correlation
so a hundred percent of causally related items
have a correlation right.
A hundred percent correlation.
Well not necessarily, but it implies correlation
but it does not prove it.
But zero.
That’s bad.
That means those things aren't related.
Now, if you think about it, you can understand
why.
They have to be unrelated because if you embodied
your abstractions, then you wouldn't be able
to experiment with them.
You’d just act them out and then bang you’d
be dead.
So you have to separate the cognitive activity
from the embodiment completely so you can
choose which of your potential selves to incarnate
so to speak.
Now, the prefrontal cortex is a complex place,
and the lower parts of it seem to be more
related to the relation between cognitive
activity and the control of behavior.
But we have tried fifty tasks, I bet, trying
to get a correlation with conscientiousness
and we haven't found one.
We cannot.
The reason I’m telling you this is because
conscientiousness is a very good predictor
of long term life success.
You guys get your grades for two reasons.
One, you're smart - assuming you are - and
two, that you work hard - assuming that you
do.
That eats up almost all the variance in your
grades.
Creativity is zero correlation with grades
at U of T, by the way which I think is extraordinarily
comical, and completely unsurprising.
It’s hard for an institution to grade creativity
cause it’s an institution, and the problem
with being creative is that you force people
to come up with a new grading scheme.
It’s like no, they're not gonna do that.
Right, because you come up with something
creative, it’s different.
Well what do you do with that?
You say, don’t do that.
That’s not what I want, even if it’s a
great thing.
It’s like yeah yeah, take your great thing
and go somewhere else with it.
I’ve got five minutes to mark your damn
paper.
So anyways, this capacity for abstraction
is divorced almost completely from embodiment,
and that's a good thing because that allows
us to experiment.
But it’s a bad thing because actually doing
the embodiment turns out to be very difficult.
It’s like your body’s got all these habits
built into it that you've been working on
for a long time.
Here's another piece of advice.
Do not practice things that you don't want
to become because one of the things that happens.
Let’s say you take Danish speakers and you
play Danish backwards to them, and you do
a scan of brain activity.
It’s like their brain’s lighting up like
mad because they don’t know how to say Danish
backwards, so you get a whole bunch of brain
involved in a new task.
But then as you practice the task, and routinize
it, less and less brain is involved.
So what happens is - this is in your standard,
right-hand male and the reason I’m doing
that as an example is that’s kind of the
simplest default brain in a sense.
Women are more diffusely organized, and so
it’s harder to exactly talk about their
neurological structure in a simple way, but
in a right-handed male, what happens is the
activity starts to shift to the left, and
then it shifts backwards, and as it does so,
the amount of tissue that gets activated gets
smaller and smaller and smaller and smaller
until you've built a little machine that takes
care of that sort of thing.
But the thing about that machine is that it’s
a machine.
It’s a habit, and it’s actually there.
It’s built into you.
So be careful what you practise because if
you practise it enough, it becomes - it’s
like it’s you.
It’s the default you.
And then if you want to change it, you can't
just undo that stupid machine.
It’s there permanently.
What you have to do is you have to build another
little machine that shuts it off, and then
another machine that does the other thing,
and then if you get stressed the little machine
that shuts the first machine off will stop
working and back your stupid habit will come.
So, people used to talk about the development
of character, and there was something about
that that was absolutely right because character
is how you build yourself across time, and
it really really matters.
Only practise what you want to become.
If you practise other things, then well you’ll
become them.
That’s not so good.
Okay, so back to this.
Now, Gray and Sokolov and Vinogradova.
We’re gonna talk about them for a minute.
Now, they used to talk about animals.
They're mostly thinking about animals - rats,
mostly - as having an expectancy model.
So you take a rat.
You throw him in a new environment.
What does he do?
Well the first he does is freeze because god
only knows what’s out there.
So it’s like paralyzed rat; he’s just
seen the Medusa.
He’s paralyzed, and then if nothing attacks
him, he starts to calm down a bit and then
he’ll start sniffing because rats are all
smell.
And he sniffs around, and he’s trying to
detect cats, say.
Now, rats have such a good sense of smell.
If a rat eats somethign that makes it sick,
it’ll never eat it again.
But, if a rat smells the breath of a rat that
ate something that made it sick, he won’t
eat that either.
Right, so rats eh.
Man, they can smell things.
And animals are built around a smell brain,
so they're a lot different than us.
We have - did I tell you about the t-shirt
study of symmetrical men?
Oh that’s a funny one.
So we know that one of the things that signify
physical beauty is symmetry, and the reason
for that is that all things considered, symmetrical
people are more healthy than asymmetrical
people.
Asymmetry indicates taht somethings gone wrong
somewhere in the process of development.
So, we like symmetry and beauty.
And that's fine.
That’s all the way across the animal kingdom.
So butterflies.
There are butterflies that wont mate with
another butterfly if it deviates from symmetry
some absurdly tiny amount.
Like really, it’s micro measurement deviation.
I gues they have a butterfly template and
if you know, the potential mating butterfly
doesn't match, it’s like flitter off.
You’re not getting anywhere.
So, that's fine.
So symmetry.
This researcher, god only knows what possessed
him, took a bunch of men, ranging from symmetrical
to asymmetrical - judged by a panel - and
then he had them shower and then he had them
wear a t-shirt for like four hours.
And then, he gave these t-shirts to women
and he said okay rate the scent of the t-shirt
from positive to negative.
Well the women overwhelmingly preferred the
symmetrical guys.
Yeah, no kidding eh.
So you just bloody well never know what’s
behind that attraction.
We know some things.
Symmetry’s a big one, but there’s a bunch
of other ones too.
I was just wondering how that would correlate
with - I know attraction to smells also has
to do with your optimal mate.
Oh yeah, there’s a bunch of things.
Here's another study - this is a cool one.
This is one of the few psychological facts.
We don't have many psychological facts, you
know.
We have a lot of hypotheses about things but
this is as close to a fact as we've ever got.
So, back decades ago, these Israeli children
were raised in kibbutzim, and those were basically
- they were basically daycare for kids.
Group day care.
But the kids were more separated from the
parents than they might be in a regular day
care.
Anyways, all the Israeli kids were in these
kibbutzim, and so then we have detailed marriage
records of the kids.
You know that people very seldom marry their
siblings, and they're very seldomly in a sexual
relationship with their siblings, and you
might say well why is that.
It’s the case across cultures, with very
specific exceptions like often high rank nobility
- they have an option.
Generally speaking, there's a powerful incest
taboo, as well as between parents and children.
So, some researcher decided well how do you
know who you're sibling is, you know roughly
speaking.
What exactly is it that’s not turning you
on, let’s say.
Well so they checked out the kibbutzim records
and they found that Israeli children who were
raised in the same kibbutzim never married
each other.
Whatever happened seemed to - it was as if
that close, close contact in the very early
years triggered whatever the sibling anti-response
is and that was that.
It’s probably smell.
That would be my guess.
Now, there’s also another study.
One of the things they found with mice - I
hope it’s mice - is that mice will not mate
- is that right?
Okay, I’m gonna garble this up but it doesn't
matter because the underlying point is valid
even though I’m gonna mess up the details.
Animal studies indicated, if I remembered
correctly, that mice will not mate with other
mice who have an RH factor that would increase
the probability of a miscarriage.
And neither will women, well not with mice
obviously, but women do not like the smell
of men who have RH factors that in combination
with theirs will produce suboptimal offspring,
and when you ask them why they don't like
the smell, they say that it’s like my brother.
Something like that.
So anyways, that’s quite remarkable.
Now back to the rats and the expectancy model.
We already know that you can get an orienting
response out of a human being if something
deviates from expectancy.
Now people started studying this in rats,
and the original conceptualization was expectation.
So you have an expectation about how the world
is gonna lay itself out.
That’s your model, and then if the world
deviates from that, you have an orienting
reflex and what that does is protect you from
predation.
That’s the first level of the orienting
response.
It’s really, really primitive.
It’s mediated only by a few neuronal connections
so it’s unbelievably rapid.
Then after that, there’s anxiety and the
proclivity to explore.
That both gets activated.
So it’s first protective, then you orient
towards the - imagine you're walking down
the street and hear a really loud noise behind
you.
It’s like really loud, so it startles you.
Well you go into a crouch so that if a tiger
had jumped on your back, it would be hard
for it to get your neck, and then tenths of
a second later, you'll turn assuming you don't
get attacked by a tiger, you’ll swivel and
turn and orient all your senses towards the
locale that was specified by the sound because
you have a stereo auditory system and you
can localize events in space using that.
So you orient towards it - that’s part of
the orienting reflex.
It’s a reflex.
It’s not voluntary.
So, and then once you've got your eyes trained
on it, and your ears, then you start to explore
it and then you might freeze.
You might get out of there which is a panic
response.
That’s another thing that could be triggered
by the orienting reflex.
Different circuit.
Or you might think, “Wow, what’s going
on over there?
It looks interesting.”
And then you go approach it.
Now, those two - the exploratory part is mediated
in part by the hypothalamus which is a very
very old system, and it has a whole section,
about half of it is devoted to the circuitry
that you would use to figure out what was
going on if something that you didn't understood
happened.
And then you have a whole other circuit that’s
hippocampal and amygdalic that regulates the
exploratory circuit and says be careful because
while you're gathering information, you might
get killed and the anxiety circuit takes primacy,
generally speaking, over the exploratory circuit.
And the reason for that is you don't want
to get information and be dead so caution
is the watchword.
Now, the other thing you might think about
which is an extremely useful thing to think
about.
Okay let’s go back to that diagram I showed
you with the hierarchy.
Right, so you’ve got the motor actions at
the bottom, and you've got the high level
abstractions at the top.
So, you're tickling the baby and somebody
comes home and says if you tickle the baby
this way, the baby has more fun.
And so how do you respond to that?
Well maybe you’re a little peeved because
you're doing perfectly fine with this baby
and someone’s coming and altering your tickling
micro personality, and you know, if you're
irritable you’ll say well why don't you
just go off and find a baby of your own to
play with.
And if you're not that irritable, you might
say well okay show me what to do.
There’ll be a tinge of negative emotion
there, generally speaking, depending on how
the person has approached you but your self
concept can probably handle a micro change
to your tickling routine.
Okay, so that’s gonna produce only a little
bit of anxiety and irritation and the reason
for that is that the threat to you is proportionate
to the magnitude of the system that's being
modified by the challenge.
Now this is really useful to know, okay, practically,
and this is why.
Let’s say you’re having an argument with
your partner and you say, you’re a stupid
person and you’ve always been a stupid person
and as far as I can tell, as far into the
future as I can see, you’re going to remain
a stupid person.
So what are they supposed to do?
What are they gonna do when you say that?
They’re gonna cry like if you mean it.
They're gonna get angry if you mean it, and
they’ll not like you very much, and why
is that?
Well it’s like, it’s assault basically.
The only thing you can do in a situation like
that is walk away, ignore it, respond in kind,
or it degenerates into violence.
That’s it because there's no discussion.
You haven't left the person anywhere to go.
You’ve gone right to the top of their hierarchy
and said everything about you is wrong, and
worse than that, all the mechanisms that we
could use to correct it won’t work.
So, those are fighting words.
So don’t do that unless you want to have
a fight.
So then you might say, well what would you
do instead?
And the answer is deliver the least amount
of information you possibly can, and so let’s
say you come home and your person is watching
TV, and you were kind of hoping they’d greet
you at the door.
You shouldn't break down into tears and say
you’re a stupid person, you’ve always
been a stupid person, and you’re gonna be
a stupid person in the future.
You should say, I have this peculiarity and
that is when I come home, I don't have enough
confidence to just be happy.
I would like you to come and say - just shut
the TV off for two minutes, come to the front
door and say “Hello”, and then you can
go back and watch your TV.
Would it be okay if you did that?
And they'll think, “Okay you’ll have to
pay for it somehow,” but then they'll probably
do it.
But the thing is you’ve got to specify the
routine that you want transformed at the highest
possible level of resolution, and you want
to recommend the minimal necessary change
that will satisfy you.
So you can't say, “If you love me, you'd
know how to greet me at the door.”
Ha.
Not helpful because they're stupid.
Right, and so are you.
So you have to spell it out.
It’s like what do you want.
Exactly, what would make you satisfied, and
then you have to have your person grudgingly
practice that a few times and you have to
let them do it very badly and also in a bad
temper, and then you'd have to reward them
for it and then maybe three months later,
they'll do it properly.
So you need to know that because that's what
people are like.
It’s very hard for them to learn new things,
and they're very resistant to it, but they're
very responsive to reward.
So another thing - this is partly what B.F.
Skinner figured out so, when he was training
rats and he wanted a rat to do something,
one of the things he would do is put - maybe
he was gonna train the rat to climb up a little
ladder, and I mean he can get rats to climb
ladders and climb across the little monkey
bars and then spin around three times and
then, you know, whack a ball and then eat
something, like he got incredibly complex
behavior out of rats.
And the way he did that was patience.
So he put the ladder in the cage, and the
rat would just run around doing rat things,
and it would put its hand on the first rung,
and Skinner would give it a pellet, and so
after even once, the rat’s gonna be like
standing in the immediate vicinity of the
ladder and then the frequency with which its
gonna go like this has just increased so its
gonna do it again.
Bang, pellet.
Well soon the rat’s just going like this,
right?
So then, you wait until the rat tries the
other hand.
So you give it a pellet then.
Well then it’s going like this and then
because it’s going to get bored, it’ll
go like this.
It’ll hit the next stair.
Bang, you give it a pellet.
Soon the rat is climbing and doing all the
little things he wanted to do.
Now the problem with that is you have to be
patient.
You have to wait until the rat does what you
want.
Okay that’s more relationship advice.
Wait till the rat does what you want, and
then reward it, and it’s unbelievably useful.
It’s also extraordinarily positive.
I mean I’m being, you know, comical, insofar
as I can manage that, about the situation,
but people love reward and they love attention.
People love attention more than anything else,
and so if you watch through the day, and when
your partner does something that’s good,
say “Bam, that was good” or something
like that.
You can be inventive, and then they'll do
it more, and if you do that a whole bunch
like for a year, they'll be doing things that
are good for you just all the time.
But you have to be patient, which is very
annoying and you have to suppress your response
to only respond to negative things, you know,
because what we know about the expectancy
models is that a deviation from expectation
produces a burst of negative emotion.
So you come home, and the whole house is clean,
but there’s like - I don’t know - the
dog has shed on the rug or something and the
person overlooked that.
It’s like you're not gonna see the clean
house, you’re gonna see the rug with the
dog fur on it and you’re gonna say “Why
didn't you clean up the rug with the dog fur?”
And they're gonna say, “Good luck getting
me to clean the house again.”
And you know, because the thing is the exception
stands out and what’s done doesn’t, and
the reason for that is you can just ignore
what’s done because it’s done.
It doesn't get in your way.
So it just gets invisible really quickly.
So you really gotta watch that tendency.
One of the things Nietzsche said was that
if you really want to punish someone, you
don't punish them when they do something wrong
because they expect that.
That’s not a punishment, they expect that.
They might even be relieved by it.
You want to punish them when they do something
right because then you'll really hurt them.
So that's something to think about, if you're
in a relationship man.
If someone’s done something right, do not
punish them.
You do that two or three times and that’s
it man.
You’re not gonna get them to do that anymore.
So, judiciousness.
Watch what they're doing.
If something happens that’s good, notice
it, and you know, if they’ve done a bunch
of things don’t concentrate on the things
they did wrong.
That’s not smart.
It’s really hard on them too.
In some sense this sounds manipulative and
selfish, you know, because I’m teaching
you how to train your partner, but you should
also teach them how to train you because it
would be really nice if you could come home
and the person would say, “Well what did
you do today?”
and you say “Here’s a bunch of things
I did.”
and they say “Well this looks really good,
and that was great, and why don't you do some
more of that?”
And you’re like “Oh boy,” it was a great
day.
So, you can train them to train you properly,
and that's a really helpful thing especially
when you do it over a few years.
That's how you have a good relationship because
you're both clueless as hell to begin with.
You don’t know even what would make you
happy, much less what would make the other
person happy and so you've got to figure these
things out bit by bit and you have to inform
each other, and you have to be patient enough
to let your partner do these things really
badly.
I’ll give you another example.
Sometimes I see couples sporadically in my
clinical practice.
I’m not a couples counsellor, but sometimes
when I'm working with someone, there's an
issue that needs to be discussed with both
people because otherwise it’s just stupid,
and one of the things I often recommend to
people especially once they have kids is that
they set aside - to use an anachronistic phrase
- date nights.
Well, everyone hates that idea.
They say, well you know, they’ll just say,
“I’m not doing that.”
That’d be one objection.
“We’re just not doing that.
That’s what we did before we got married.”
They'll say, “Well my partner will never
go for that.”
They've got a bunch of excuses why that isn't
going to work, and so I've heard all those
excuses.
I’ve heard all of them, and then maybe I
convince them, “Yeah, yeah, I know this
is stupid.
It’s awkward.
It’s artificial.
That’s okay.
Just try it once.”
So then they'll go and try it, and then they'll
come back and say, “We had an absolutely
miserable time.
Really.
We had a miserable time.
We couldn't agree on what movie to go to,
and then she took me to her movie and I really
didn't like it and so we fought all the way
home.
We’re never doing that again.”
And I say, well really, you’ve got thirty
years, four hundred days.
That’s twelve thousand days.
Okay, so you're not going to do that.
You’re going to spend the next twelve thousand
days without having any real romantic evenings
and interactions with your spouse.
That's your plan.
And I like doing arithmetic with my clients.
They hate that.
They hate arithmetic.
It’s like well no that sounds like a bad
idea.
Okay well would you like some romance in your
life or are you just done with that?
Well really, like people can go for a long
time with no romance at all.
They say, “Well no maybe, we’d like some
of that.”
Well how much?
Once a year.
Well, no.
Once a month.
Once every two weeks.
Well, sometimes people are really busy.
Okay, that beats the hell out of zero.
Once a week, twice a week.
Okay, whatever, we’re gonna start with a
range.
Okay, what would a good evening look like?
Like if you could both get exactly what you
wanted, what would it look like?
Then they have to think about that because
the previous theory was, “My stupid partner
should know what I like” and that's what
the partner is thinking too.
It’s like good luck with that, no they don't
have a clue especially if they're men.
They don't have a clue so you have to tell
them what you want and how they could deliver
it, and vice versa which is very awkward and
horrible.
And then you have to practice it for six months
because you know, it takes a lot of practice
to do something sophisticated really well,
and then if you do that it’s like poof,
you got it for the rest of your life.
So it’s worth the aggravation, and you know
the first time the rat puts its paw on the
ladder, its just sort of doing it accidentally.
You can't expect it to do it well, and that's
exactly how to view your own progress and
the progress of your partner.
It’s like let them do it badly for awhile.
At least they're doing it.
So if you think they should do it faster,
well look real hard and see how easy it is
to change your own behavior because it’s
really hard to change your own behavior.
Everybody says, “I’m going to exercise
three times a week.”
New Years, and its like no one does.
They buy the membership and then they feel
guilty for having them, but they don't actually
go to the gym - and that's a perfect example
of how difficult it is to transform behavior.
Okay, so back to the diagram here.
Expectation.
So, the early models of expectation were cognitive
models and the idea was the rat makes a little
model of the world, and then he operates in
that world according to what he expects.
Now there's a problem with that model.
There's a bunch of them.
The first is now we know that animals don't
make comprehensive models of the world, and
that's a huge problem.
The problem is, well what do they get rid
of, and how?
But the way you get rid of that problem is
that you introduce motivation into the equation,
and it’s interesting because the behaviorists
always thought of animals like blank slates
so they never really took motivation seriously
as a contributor to cognitive modeling.
It’s also the case that probably ever since
the Enlightenment, people have thought of
emotion and motivation as forces opposed to
rationality.
So you know, you're as rational insofar as
you didn't let your emotions and motivations
influence you.
But that's a foolish theory.
There are times when it’s inappropriate
for certain purposes to let certain motivations
interfere with your observations, but generally
speaking you never think about anything without
being motivated because why would you?
Like, there’s a trillion things you can
think of and you're not gonna think of most
of them.
You have to have a reason to think of them,
and the reason is that, well, all the time
you're operating in some sort of motivational
structure, and you can sort of model them
using the same kind of hierarchy that we use
to model the personality as such.
I’ll give you an example.
So let’s think of some basic motivations
and emotions.
Those aren't good categories by the way because
there's no such things as motivations and
there's no such thing as emotions.
The things we loosely categorize into motivations
and emotions each have their own brain circuitry,
and so there are similarities between them
and there are differences.
They're not clean categories.
Well, we’re gonna use the terminology anyways
because we don't have a better one.
For my purposes, you can roughly define a
motivation as opposed to an emotion as a motivation
is really something that establishes, you
could say, a goal, but it doesn’t.
It establishes one of these.
It doesn't establish a goal, and it doesn't
drive behavior.
So what it does is let’s say you're hungry
and it’s nighttime, and you want to have
a peanut butter sandwich.
So imagine you're sitting there typing away,
and all of a sudden this little image of having
something to eat creeps into your head.
It’s not usually quite specific.
It’s that there's something you would like
to eat.
So you think, “Ah, I could really use some
popcorn.”
So you're typing away and the stupid popcorn
thing keeps popping up, and finally your whole
body is starting to get into the popcorn and
you think “Oh to hell with it, I’ll go
make some popcorn.”
So what's happened is that your hypothalamus,
roughly speaking, is monitoring your internal
body state and it thinks that you need some
- maybe you need some salt, but maybe you
need some food, and so it’s gonna start
popping up, not a drive.
It’s not like all of a sudden you’re a
robot, like a popcorn seeking robot and you're
laying out your chained together condition
popcorn making and eating routines.
That isn't what happens.
What happens instead that you start to envision
a new state of being, and that state of being
has a goal which is you eating some popcorn,
and it has you where you are which is in an
insufficient state of popcorn and then what's
happening as well is that the motor processes
that you would use to implement that are also
disinhibited.
They're there.
You already know how to do it.
They get disinhibited or you can think of
them as getting primed.
They're not.
They're getting disinhibited, but you can
think of them as getting primed.
And at some point, that becomes overwhelming
enough - say, pressure from the hypothalamus
which is really what's bloody well in control.
It says yeah, yeah, enough internet surfing.
Off to the popcorn, and so you leap up and
then what do you do?
You reorient the way you're looking at the
world.
Everything in the world becomes low resolution,
or even zero except those few things that
are relevant to your new quest.
Down the stairs you go.
You find the right pan; you find the popcorn,
getting irritated if you can't find it, right,
because - now you see it’s interesting because
your emotions align along your goals.
As long as you're pursuing a beeline to your
goal, and everything's laying itself out not
as you’d expect, but as you want, then your
emotions stay positive but as soon as something
deviates then you're irritated, and the reason
for that is like let’s say you can't find
a popcorn pan.
Well your brain is computing, well something
like this.
This is obviously not how it works, but it’s
an - x amount of energy and matter from popcorn
means it has x value.
If you expend a whole bunch of energy running
around in your clueless state trying to acquire
popcorn, you can easily get to the point where
you've expended more energy and time than
the popcorn delivers.
And if you do that for a month, then you die.
So it’s perfectly reasonable for you to
get irritated when the path length to your
destination increases radically, and you might
get even more irritated if you can’t find
any popcorn, and it’s like oh no I have
to dispense with the popcorn micro personality
and it’s all irritated because it’s sort
of alive.
It’s irritated you have to squash it, and
then you have to come up with well maybe I
can have a peanut butter sandwich.
And then pop, up comes a new micro personality
that orients itself towards the goal, and
so all the time you’re doing that, you're
always in a motivated state.
Now, it’s not a drive because it’s not
deterministic, but it does have a behavioral
element.
You have all these Piagetian subroutines.
They're stored in your body, you know, all
your body capacity or your skills.
And you know which set of those you’re likely
to use if you’re going to do x thing.
So those get prepared, and then your perceptions
reorient towards the new goal.
It’s like a hunting goal.
You're fixated on it, and then your emotions
orient along that so as long as things are
going well, you're happy.
You’re hopeful.
Things are proceeding.
That’s positive emotion; that’s dopaminergically
mediated, and if things aren't going well
it’s either, well, it’s any amount of
negative emotion from mild irritation to full
blown temper tantrum.
So that’s - and you’re - okay that’s
the simple story.
The complex story is okay, you’re hungry,
you’re thirsty, you’re tired, you’re
hot, you’re lonely.
You need to play.
Okay, so let's say you've got, for the sake
of argument, let’s say you have eight fundamental
motivational systems.
Now, who cares how many.
It’s a finite set.
It’s under twenty.
Depends on whether you include anger.
Is anger motivation or emotion?
Is pain motivation or emotion?
We don’t care because they're not formal
categories.
So anyways, there's a set number of them and
then so they have to run to satiation.
So what satiation means is they set up an
end state; you perform the routines, you achieve
the end state, and the system shuts down.
It’s satiated.
Now you'll experience that as satisfaction,
not as pleasure.
And you’ll think well what's the difference?
It’s tight.
It’s complicated, but it’s important.
The kind of positive emotion that people really
like is associated with search and the hope,
not with the acquiry because what happens
when you acquire is well you're no longer
in this state which has an impulse to action
in it, but that's exciting.
That’s fun.
You're on the track of something.
It’s like you’re alive while you're searching
for something.
Well then you find it.
It’s like good, you need to find it, but
then the whole thing disappears and you're
sitting there thinking well I’ve just graduated.
Now what?
Right, because that’s what’ll happen when
you graduate.
It’s like hey you're a student.
You've got status.
You’ve got a hierarchy of values.
You've got a way of orienting yourself in
the world, and you have an identity.
So you're in there, and everyone's happy about
it and so one day you graduate.
It’s like success.
Well really, it’s like poof that’s gone,
and the next thing you know, you’re like
handing out coffee at the local Starbucks.
Yeah, well you get the point.
You've experienced this all the time in your
life.
You hit a pinnacle.
You've obtained something, but the problem
is that now what?
You have to conjure up a whole new you.
So some of it is satisfying, you’ve accomplished
a goal, but some of it’s just a big pain
in the neck.
It’s like uh oh, student me has disappeared
and now it’s frantically searching for employment
me, and that me doesn't have the status, and
is in a space of much more radical uncertainty.
So don't be thinking that getting to where
you want to go is what you want.
What you want is to bloody well make sure
that the voyage is worth it.
Now it’s very interesting because people
are really wired up this way, and I think
it’s because we’re so radically exploratory.
So, when you’re proceeding towards a valued
goal, let’s call that a cue that goal attainment
is about to occur.
It’s going to occur in some chain.
A leads to B, B leads to C, C leads to D,
and so on.
You're like a hound on a trail.
It’s positive, like yeah this is working.
Yeah, this is working.
That’s positive.
It’s moving you ahead, and that's really
where you experience a lot of your positive
emotion.
That’s dopaminergically mediated.
That’s the system you kick with cocaine
or any of the other drugs of abuse that people
use that don't quell anxiety.
It’s a very, very desirable motivational
state.
I read awhile back somebody who said you can
buy anything but you can't buy wanting anything,
and that's a staggeringly interesting comment
because you think well, is wanting a positive
state?
Well you don't have it, so that's kind of
annoying and you think, “No I don't want
to want things.
I want to have them.”
It’s like yeah, don’t be so sure about
that.
So one of the things, one of the ways people
have figured out how to deal with that is
they decide they want something that they
can't get and that's actually extraordinarily
smart, and it’s a deep archetypal idea.
Here’s an example.
You’ve seen Pinocchio, right?
Okay, so Pinocchio is about a puppet, a marionette.
So that means someone else is pulling his
strings.
Right?
We don't know who.
Sometimes it’s virtually Satan himself.
Remember the Stromboli?
There's another character just after him is
the coachman.
The coachman, he’s like king of the thieves
and he ends up pulling Pinocchio’s strings.
So there’s one scene in the Disney movie
where the coachman reveals himself and he’s
completely red, he has really big teeth; he’s
a satanic figure, and he scares the fox and
the cat who are like low level criminals who
think they're bad, but you know, have never
really met bad.
He just scares them right into the corner,
and so it’s all of a sudden this person
reveals the archetype behind and just closes
back down pulling Pinocchio’s strings.
Okay, now.
He’s a marionette.
Well, the first question that arises is who’s
pulling your strings?
And that’s a really good question.
One of the things Jung said was “People
don't have ideas, ideas have people.”
You know, you can think about that for about
three months and it should make you afraid
the whole time because as soon as you get
that, you think uh oh.
Let’s say you're an ideologue of some sort
because some of you probably are: socialist,
fascist, environmentalist, something that
has -ist on the end.
It’s like you think those are your ideas.
They’re not.
You're their tools and that's fine.
If you want to be a tool of those ideas, you
go right ahead, but you don't know where those
ideas are leading and they could well be leading
somewhere you do not want to go.
Now the plus side is you don't have to take
responsibility for it because you’re just
drifting in an ocean of thought.
But one of the things that I learned from
Jung was you should figure out just exactly
which ideas are possessing you and then you
should decide if those are your ideas, and
the probability that they are is zero.
They’re not your ideas.
It’s hard to have your own ideas.
You have to derive them from your own experience,
and especially when you're not very old, you
don't have that much experience and so you
can grab books full of ideas and claim them
for your own which is not acceptable.
You can use those ideas to inform your ideas,
but they're not your ideas.
You're just a puppet, and you know the Pinocchio
movie is very interesting that way because
he's a puppet of forces that are really not
on his side.
Seriously not on his side.
Okay anyways, back to the Pinocchio movie.
Give me one second.
So Geppetto doesn't have a son.
Now, Geppetto’s a good guy right?
He’s a toymaker.
He’s got this little warm cabin.
It’s cozy.
He’s a good guy.
He’s friendly.
He has a little cat.
He pays attention to his little fish, he takes
care of that.
So we know Geppetto’s a good guy and he
makes this puppet and he thinks, “Man I’ve
got a puppet but maybe I’d rather have something
real.
That’s a good question for parents.
You want a puppet, or do you want something
real?
And the answer is, generally often, I’ll
just have a puppet as long as it does exactly
what it - maybe it’ll be a medical school
puppet because that's certainly one good form
of puppet.
Okay, so Geppetto decides cause he’s a good
guy, he thinks no no I don't want this thing
to have strings.
I want it to be its own thing.
I want it to be autonomous, individual, real.
Okay, so what does he do?
He wishes.
Right?
What’s he wish on?
A star.
Why do people wish on stars?
Of all the crazy things.
Well it’s a divine thing.
It’s like there’s heaven, it’s all - it’s
at the infinite.
You go out at night and you see the stars,
which you can't in the city but you go out
somewhere dark and you see the stars, and
it’s like you and the infinite.
And it really is.
It’s a perfect representation of your relationship
with the infinite because the universe is
about as infinite as you need, and it’s
going to give you a sense of awe and that's
partly why archaic people partly thought God
was in the sky.
It’s like, they weren't stupid, these people.
They thought God is what fills you with awe,
so you look at the sky and think wow, that’s
something.
It’s an instinct.
It’s not a cognitive construction.
So anyways, you aim at a star, and it’s
this twinkling thing in the darkness, right.
It’s the light in the darkness and it’s
above the worldly environment.
It’s something transcendent.
So that’s what Geppetto wishes on.
It’s like, I’m gonna aim high.
That’s what he says.
Aim high.
And he thinks well it’s not very likely
but I might as well aim high.
That’s a very good piece of advice.
You want to aim so high you can't attain it
because then you've got something worth - you
might think that’s such perverse.
That’s such a perverse piece of advice.
Why would you chase something you can't have?
Well the answer might be cause the chasing
is worth it, and then you might think well
what’s worth it?
Well I can give you a hint about that too.
It’s like develop your character because
what you've got is what you carry with you
wherever you go, and it’s way better to
be able to do things than to be rich cause
if you're rich, well then that disappears.
Poof, you're poor.
But if you can do things short of being demolished,
and even then people are unbelievable at overcoming
those things.
It’s like you're on the way.
Here’s an interesting experiment we did
with undergraduate women.
So, there's this idea in evolutionary psychology.
It’s called hypergamy, and hypergamy is
the tendency of women to choose mates who
are slightly older than them, it’s about
four years on average cross culturally, and
who are higher in the status hierarchy than
they are.
It’s a very well documented tendency, and
people who are cynical about that think women
want wealth, and I thought well it’s not
a bad theory because it kind of evens the
scales.
It’s like you're gonna have a family.
You’re basically - a chimpanzee baby clings
to its mother’s fur for five thousand miles
in the three or four years its doing its clinging.
It’s like its a major league impediment,
and you know, if you're a new mother, your
life is so much more complicated than it is
when you were single that it’s not even
the same conceptual universe.
It’s a major league responsibility, and
it slows you down.
So you might think the logical thing to do
is to balance the scales a little bit and
that's perfectly reasonable, but I thought,
“Nah, I bet you women are smarter than that.”
I bet you can fool them, and the pick up artists
do that all the time because they mimic status.
So, you can fool them but they're smart.
So what we did - I never published this for
a bunch of reasons, but.
Okay so what we did was we took pictures of
the same guy - you know kind of an average
looking guy.
He’s alright, and we had four stories about
him, and one story was a poor useless guy.
That’s an easy story right.
You know, sits on his couch, plays video games,
eats Cheetos, covered with dust.